[Music]
how does a case reach the Supreme Court
through appeal from a Circuit Court and
what other two ways under the courts
original jurisdiction or an appeal from
a state Supreme Court a party can appeal
by filing a petition for a writ of
certiorari which is Latin for to inform
and what are the four types of Supreme
Court opinions majority opinions
concurring opinions dissenting opinions
and per curiam opinion which means from
the court wrong per curiam means by the
court players get into the hall of fame
why be used after retirement any player
with 10 years of experience may be
nominated by the Baseball Writers
Association of America members vote for
up to 10 candidates players who are on
75% of the ballots are nominated is
there another way there's also a
veteran's committee made of a force
subcommittee each specializing in a
different era and the four subcommittees
are 1988 to present day 1972 1987 1950
to 1969 and 1881 to 1949 wrong 1871 to
1949 what are some causes of the French
Revolution
conflict between the monarchy and the
nobility and the ineffective leadership
of louis xvi
and the agrarian crisis of 1788 which
led to food shortages and the
Enlightenment illuminated by famous
French philosophers such as Rousseau and
Montesquieu how do you spell matcha q mo
en te q IE you Ron there's an extra u in
there somewhere
name all the elements of the periodic
table all of them yes all of them okay
hydrogen helium lithium beryllium boron
carbon nitrogen oxygen bromine krypton
rubidium strontium einsteinium fermium
mendelevium nobelium and lawrencium
sorry I fell asleep can you start from
the beginning
No
[Applause]